the truly big leap again in this
category of seemingly impossible is to
put a human being on mars
when do you think spacex will land a
human being on mars
hmm
best case is about five years
worst case tenures
what are the determining factors would
you say from an engineering perspective
or is that that not the bottlenecks
uh you know it's fundamentally um
you know engineering the the vehicle um
i mean starship is the most
complex and advanced rocket that's ever
been made by
i don't know order of magnitude or
something like that it's a lot
it's really next level so
um
and the fundamental optimization of
starship is minimizing cost per tonne to
orbit and ultimately cost per ton to the
surface of mars
um this may seem like a mercantile
objective but it is actually the thing
that needs to be optimized um like there
is a certain
cost per ton to the surface of mars
where we can afford to establish a
self-sustaining uh city
um and the and then above that we cannot
afford to do it
um so right right now you couldn't fly
to mars for a trillion dollars doesn't
no amount of money could get your ticket
to mars
so we need to get that above
uh you know to get that like something
that is actually possible at all um
um but but then but that's that's
we don't we don't just want to have
you know with mars flags and footprints
and then not come back for a half
century like we did with the moon
uh
in order to
pass a very important great filter i
think we we need to be a multi-planet
species
um
unless we sound somewhat esoteric to
to a lot of people but
uh
like eventually given enough time
uh
that's something
the earth is likely to experience
some calamity um that could be
uh
something that humans do to themselves
or an external event like happen to the
dinosaurs um
and
um but a bit of you know eventually
and if if not if none of that happens
and somehow magically we keep going uh
then the sun will the sun is gradually
expanding
um and will engulf the earth um and
probably earth gets too hot for
uh life in
uh
about 500 million years it's a long time
but that's only 10 percent longer than
earth has been around
and so if you think about like the
because the current situation is really
remarkable um and kind of hard to
believe but
uh
it's been around four and a half billion
years and this is the first time if one
half billion years that has been
possible to extend life beyond earth
and that window opportunity may be open
for a long time and i hope it is but it
also may be open for a short time and we
should uh i think it was
wise for us to
act quickly while the window is open
just in case it closes
you